you know conspiracies get me in trouble
sometimes and make headlines but does
nobody think it's weird that the mazva
doll drama all that's gone away do you
think maybe the UFC Went to went hey
draw by that stuff you come back with
your title shot drop all that
because when you have maswell fight
Gilbert Burns we need to move on this
can delay everything drop it and we'll
give you a title shot put yourself in
Kobe's shoes do you think you're gonna
make more money suing Mazda doll for
that incident outside the Miami
restaurant or do you think you'll make
more money fighting Leon Edwards for a
world title shot it'd be a tough fight
for Leon the potential make more monies
in fighting for a world title on
pay-per-view or suing Jorge Mazda